I wish you came to the thing I want you
to come to the house I know it's far
from you
like come bring your family I have like
five bedrooms come and just stay yeah on
the Long Island yeah there's a pro I
just got a great hot tub it's nice
here's a problem with that and that's
far dude it's not far it's the [ __ ]
that Highway
yeah I know it's the highway of death
it's it's the highway of death it's the
saddest [ __ ] ever
I mean you know Louis has his house on
shelter are we going we're recording
okay yeah Louis has his house on Shelter
Island I remember when he first got it
he called me up
when I just had Max and he's like we're
having a big party please come
you can stay here
and you could you could have the yacht
you could stay on the yacht he had that
beautiful teak yacht
and I I was like I no like it was
Saturday it's like summer I am not I
can't be in the car with a baby for six
hours it's a it's a tough ride you need
to buy a helicopter yeah it's a tough
ride you need to get your own helicopter
but that's the way they like it because
they have that one Road in and out ugh
yeah I know well I just I extended the
invite no dude I wanted to go so bad I
really imagine like January it's it'll
be fun it's like snowing I would come
out when nobody is coming there but I've
come out on a Thursday come out on a
Thursday I will not I can't Friday yeah
I think your party was on a Saturday
right it was Labor Day Monday yeah it
was Monday Labor Day weekend and I told
my wife to go listen Tim and we both
looked at each other like dude there's
no way I know I thought yeah didn't
Aaron get a helicopter Aaron and
Christine got a helicopter
how it's I think it's cheap to rent them
you can rent a helicopter yeah you could
take like an Uber but in a helicopter I
love Aaron but that's all that seems
like it'd be a lot of money well it's
also it didn't land at the house
so he's got to tell everyone that he did
it like he's walking around the party
going I took a i hey I took a helicopter
like because otherwise it's you just
walked in like everyone else yeah I love
him too I love him but it's when he was
on a helicopter it didn't make me want
to go through his taxes yeah I was like
how look I know you're I think it's not
that much how much it's I think you
could
take a helicopter from New York City to
The Hamptons you could rent it five
bills 1500 bucks dude 1500 bucks to go
to a [ __ ] party it's a lot it's not a
lot it's outrageous I'm I didn't I
didn't tell him to do it I'm just saying
it I agree it's like what I mean did you
have industry there were you giving away
what were your party favors we had a
great spread of food right but there was
no industry what did you get
um there was a Mr Softee truck that
pulled up I have that at my party in
Westchester it costs 68 bucks in an Uber
from New York City yeah I have I have I
have Jimmy soft serve show up okay and
you can get it every year at Max's
birthday party you can get as much as
you want yeah root beer float you'll
[ __ ] lose your mind well
as much as you want you you won I mean
dude you got me Long Island is a I mean
it's a it's a it's a it's a it's a job
yeah it's a choice yeah it's when you
were like I I when you were like I'm
having this party in Long Island it gave
me it gave me like I felt sad like I was
like [ __ ] I felt depressed well it's
supposed to depress you the party was
kind of depressing why well because
Louis was there who I love but I
remember like he a couple years ago
would have been it like Jack Nicholson's
house but he was hanging out with Luis
Gomez and he was enjoying it and seeing
that seeing him enjoy it that was what
made me go man it's tough well dude I
went Louie you ever go to the one of
Louie's parties at his house no I just
became friends with them in the list I
went to his house once he made me a
steak dude he threw I remember he one
year he invited us all over Thanksgiving
Norton me Nick de Paulo
um oh I forgot dude uh it was a Oscar
event yeah I imagine it was all dude it
was I think like four Oscar winners yeah
uh the guy from Scarface who got thrown
out of the helicopter
what was his name I forgot huge actor
Fame he opened the door hello wow Joan
Rivers walks in daughter
[Music]
sorry I'm dyslexic and stupid she was
playing with Max like tickling his feet
crazy dude the mother from The Exorcist
yeah and who's the guy who died great
actor uh kind of looks like you a little
bit maybe it could be your brother
um he was in uh Boogie Nights Chris Penn
no Boogie Nights gay guy tried to kiss
Mark Wahlberg I'm blanking I suck too
this sucks getting old because you can't
tell stories I had I had I had Rosebud
Baker Mike Feeney oh wow I mean wow I
had you know dude
um what the hell is his name and
Gianna's Papa's I love you I love you
these are people at the cape I mean I
don't know anyone it's at that level you
you do I mean Louie well Louie's of
course there and I know a few people but
they would never come to a party of mine
like they would text their fans of the
podcast has some really big actors that
would text me and go that you're funny I
don't think they'd ever come if you had
a place in Westchester maybe they come
yeah you you should have went
Westchester I can I I can sell this
place you should have went West if you
go Westchester dude you got Ryan
Reynolds up there yeah that's why I'm
gonna live there there's no beach Bobby
we got the beach we got the seafood we
got the Long Island state it's the
greatest place in the world it's hack
it's not it's the crack it's the
greatest place and westchester's not
dude Westchester is best Chester dude
I'm telling you right now dude I'm
telling you this is by the way one of
these geography fights we get in and
ever they know everybody hates no one
can relate but best Chester dude you you
go straight up the West Side Highway I
know well 87 you there's so many ways to
get there dude where you live it's hack
it's like cool Stern Stern Seinfeld I
mean you can't get I mean come on dude
it's footage I don't live near them
let's clarify that
down
are you on the ocean are you mentally
ill of course not what do you want I'm
in the woods nice though it's okay so
but I'm like I'm like 10 12 minutes from
a beach I'm yeah I don't like the beach
I don't like the ocean I I mean that's
you're entitled to that opinion I I I'm
a late guy I like a lake lakes are
garbage and they're for trash yeah they
are spotty dude Lakes are for men Lakes
are from man for poor man no it's
disgusting
Bobby the oceans are for men wailing
Bobby being on a ship and killing a
whale dude yeah that's for Savages dude
Savages I'll tell you what oceans are
for [ __ ] are for very rich people
Elite and the whitest of white people
okay number one that's not true but
number two I don't hear any bad things
yet okay the first of all when the
there's no hurricanes on lakes there's
no tsunamis okay you've got a point now
yeah every time there's a goddamn
weather every time God sneezes you gotta
batten down the hatches because your
house is going to be wiped away that is
to my friend her house in Florida just
gone yeah Lake goes up and down a little
bit you're done but there's nothing that
will kill you you go to the ocean it's
always cold as [ __ ] up in the Northeast
yeah and then sharks shark I mean dude
great white sharks there's an app that I
have on my phone that tracks all the
great white sharks and you know where a
lot of them are Long Island they do but
you know what a lot of them don't [ __ ]
with people they don't are you nuts they
don't [ __ ] with it it doesn't matter if
you get [ __ ] with a knot but they're
there what do you think would happen if
we put a great white shark in a lake do
you think he'd be disgusted immediately
and go like where am I you die right
away can't live in fresh water yeah I
feel like this is he'd kill himself what
are you gonna do you got Turtles and you
got Largemouth maybe a pickerel the idea
of a lake is amazing here's what I will
agree with you on the idea of a lake is
like really beautiful like a a Placid
yeah not you know like a like a a still
Lake in the morning God I I get that but
a lot of lakes are just drunks
with the beer boat you know what I'm
talking about I said you're talking
about the shitty legs like I'm talking
up in Westchester like Lake havasu's
just got their animals it's garbage yeah
these are garbage people yeah but that's
a dead Lake I mean that's the dude yeah
it's garbage okay thank you it's it's
where trash people go that's right to
die yes it's garbage it's just boats
hooked up to other boats that's right
chicks with their asses out yeah they
get drunk it's dangerous it I get scared
every time I go to the party Cove I've
been to that Lake and it it frightens me
thank you because there's so many people
but I'm talking the Northeast okay
civilized people you might be right man
you're turning me now kayaks yeah how
are you turning me okay a swimming dock
now you're turning me okay uh uh the
foliage there's a beautiful Lake
upstairs skating you can't ice skate on
the ocean Saranac Lake and there's a Old
Rockefeller Retreat there I mean no okay
I'm you're you're you're starting to
turn me a little bit on you you take a
hike on a trail it's beautiful I do want
to I do want to just for the for a
minute say that I want you to give the
ocean another chance because it is I
can't it can't open your eyes in the
water it's powerful you jump in a lake
you can open your eyes
some of them you don't have to shout out
Lake Austin what's up what's Lake Austin
it is the color of there's a um a Donkey
Kong Country get this up there's a level
in Donkey Kong Country and they swim in
the water and I don't know the name of
it
um and it's Lake Austin does not look
like any of this by the way it is a
green the color of algae green yeah yeah
that's and it's a grotesque all right
bring up Squam Lake bring up Squam Lake
New Hampshire this is the lake I'm
talking about Squam Lake is the lake
that On Golden Pond was filmed on okay
look at that dude okay I gotta be honest
look at that all right clicked that
little red Hut there look at look at
look at the little red Hut I gotta be
honest with you this that is yeah I
kayak past that that is beautiful that's
America that's quiet all right that's
quiet it's a nice mix of of Rich uh go
to Howard Stern house and hit image no
I'm kidding no listen I agree with you
in that if this is what we're talking
about I thought you were talking about
like you know look at that yeah it's
beautiful look at that little Sandbar no
you're right you're right look at that
that sand that's clean I know there I
know I mean that's five seconds away
from drinking well let's not
get hysterical yeah you look great you
feel great I feel fantastic you're happy
I'm happy and and why
um I I have AIDS
to live and it's almost over and I don't
have to plug my podcast or go on
Instagram anymore and around three and a
half months how great would it be to die
if as a straight man with a family to
just die of full-blown age full-blown
AIDS and I never and you they still
wouldn't give you a special no I
wouldn't say even if you went into HBO
and you're like I have I don't even have
HIV it's full-blown yeah I'm dying in
six months and I've never done anything
gay yeah and they'd be like we don't
believe you first of all and then second
of all yeah yeah dude I can it'd be
great it would I I have you ever thought
about like getting injured
like been in a car and be like dude if I
get in a car accident right now and I
don't want to get hurt like where I'm
dead or I'm gonna be messed up but like
a like a six month eight month hip
injury yes or I have to learn how to
walk again where I just could be out of
the business I could just take a break
yes and people would be like we get it
nobody but because we do the podcasts
people would always expect unless you
are completely dead
they would always expect a nurse to hold
a microphone to your [ __ ] mouth as I
laid there and they'd be like what do
you think about Kanye like there's it's
never ending with podcast like it never
ends there are no Seasons you still have
to do like stories of you learning how
to walk yeah oh yeah the other day the
nurse comes in I stand up like yeah it
would it's you know yeah there's no get
out of jail there's no we're in it we're
in a house it's uh Sahara
but Austin you had a good time dude
Austin was um it was great LA's a little
dead now we're all feeling this a little
death so dude when I land in LA and I
don't want to hate LA because I you know
I have a reputation of hating everything
yeah I don't I don't hate La I get La I
understand it now I get it when I land
here the sadness that comes over me it's
big it's a it's like when you go down
down even to get an Uber is just a sad
thing well you have to choose when you
live here you have to go full sociopath
yeah or it's always sad and that's the
vibe I get like even in my hotel
every male that I've run into has this
aggressive energy when they're walking
by you like who are you
what are you are you here are you taking
something from me like I don't know it's
a weird vibe like I was trying to tell
my wife about it like these guys have
all been kind of like not friendly like
nobody's really like Hi how are you it's
an isolating lonely Place everybody's
really out for themselves and they're it
can can get a little
vicious I I don't I haven't seen a ton
of aggressive people but there there's
there's different ways of being
aggressive where people are very
dismissive here it's not New York
aggressive right cuntiness no it's
dismissive yes it's this like almost
like Ugh well there's also this weird
idea that you're looking at people here
that are the
um they're still here there's a lot of
people left yeah so people went to
Nashville they went to Miami they went
to Austin they you know and some of them
are doing both and they're coming in and
they're coming back a lot of people
you're talking about the people that are
like they have that energy of like I'm
sticking it out yeah no matter how bad
it gets and it gets worse every day yeah
and then that they think that the
exterior starts to harden and they start
to become not fun yeah like even like
the guy at the hotel I was just I'm like
hey how are you man
it's like almost shocked like good like
why are you why are you talking like
that why are you yeah why are you being
nicer you know yeah because probably two
days ago a homeless guy threw pissing
and there's nothing and he moved here to
being like an actor like he moved here
to do something that's so sad and
there's a homeless guy outside [ __ ] like
full-on [ __ ] yeah and he calls the
cops and the cops go what do you want us
to do and he goes okay and then the next
and the person walks in and goes I just
stepped in [ __ ] yeah somebody's got to
clean their dog and then you guy you go
it's not a dog it's actually a person
yep oh [ __ ] I feel like fashion is a is
a big thing here too like in New York
like people are just dressed
you know regular I feel like like I've
seen so many people looking like they're
coming out of a [ __ ] magazine the
best thing about being here is you can
be ridiculous you can look ridiculous
like I can dress in like a onesie and
nobody and no one cares like I can wear
crazy half I could dress like The Lorax
yeah like in just an orange furry suit
and no one would care I went to the Ivy
the other day with uh my friend
uh Mike helter's brother and uh
and people like these couples were
coming in dressed like Johnny Depp like
both of them well that's the thing now
the new thing is
androgynous hats hats and bracelets they
look like maybe it's like kind of like
they're a ranger but like cooler yeah
it's very weird it's very like
futuristic Cowboy yes and they have all
these like uh shiny like rings and
bracelets like these yeah vegan Cowboy
yeah it's very weird and they and
they're gorgeous like everyone's very
attractive but in an odd way where you
go what would sex with them be like even
would it be good yeah it's a weird it
was a weird vibe yeah and these people
come up because you can ham you can't
help but look at them yeah because it's
such an oddity you know and I'm sitting
there with a hoodie on my friends got a
polo with you know we're all dressed
regular at this restaurant but then
these people would pull up and and come
in and they look like and it was 5 30
because that's what they want to do
that's what they're here to do that's
what all of the money they pay all the
taxes the 13 and a half percent state
tax the [ __ ] all the high High Cost
of Living the traffic the [ __ ]
Insanity all of that is for that moment
where they could walk in dress like an
androgynous Johnny Depp character and
sitted the IV and know that people like
you were gonna look at them yeah that's
their entire life yeah and then they'll
do it at a party and then they do it
like a brunch that's their entire it's a
weird thing it's their entire Austin was
the [ __ ] though I gotta say man okay I'm
gonna tell you something I went when I
was in Austin with you last time
I had a bad experience yeah I mean we
were we were I was really like what the
[ __ ] yeah it was 10 o'clock and we
couldn't find a place to eat it might
have been me
I'm very negative I I don't know it was
bad I went this time
and the Vulcan is amazing I went to the
Vulcan uh Joe invited me to go to the
Vulcan I went in
and it was off the [ __ ] chain it's
great a crowd the young Comics that were
on like Joe's yeah these guys all were
[ __ ] Killers they're all very fun I
mean really funny uh Tony was there the
crowd was off the chain
and and uh I couldn't believe how I felt
like New York it felt like the seller
like the old seller it felt like I
couldn't believe it Joe's rarely wrong I
don't think he's wrong I think when he
said Austin's gonna be a spot I think
the timeline was a bit off because I
think it's becoming one now yeah and his
club's opening in a few months but when
he sees something he did it about
podcasting he did it by MMA he calls
things early and he's right yeah dude I
I mean
I was like this is the [ __ ] and I was
talking this like they're like six clubs
his club's open yeah and he's gonna have
two clubs inside of that club I have
beef a little bit with the
characterization of Austin in the way
that it's like
people talk about it like it's the new
New York or the new and that's where you
have to go let's calm down well the new
La comedy-wise yeah sure comedy-wise
yeah you could you could make that
argument but it's just it's a small
college town that's growing right but
it's not but it's not as PC as I thought
it was no it's not like that show I was
on was very not PC well it's Rogan's
show and but they but if if he's
cultivating stand up there yeah that's
great if he's cultivating this is what
comedy is and he's doing that and those
kids all those guys on the show and
that's what I mean that's what that's
what comedy is going to be and the
people that don't like that aren't going
to go to Comedy and the people that do
are gonna go see those [ __ ] that's what
we want is I mean it's pretty I was like
[ __ ] and if you want to see like the
Austin other [ __ ] there's other stuff
you can see if you want to see the
whatever it is you can see it it doesn't
make sense to me is the hotels it's so
expensive Austin is so expensive
like Elon Musk and and Joe Rogan have
been telling people it's the place to be
so yeah it's expensive I mean I I wish
that I mean it was it's outrageous 400 a
night dude the apartments are going up
at the at the rents of are rising at
like the fastest rain
the the housing market just finally
cooled down
I mean you're talking about a year and a
half ago
even a little not even as long as that
houses were getting 30 40 offers on one
house people are closing you know 30 40
percent more than ask they had to sign
waivers going I know I'm paying an
insane amount more right because they
just wanted to get in yeah
um I don't understand though like a
Sheridan I was at a shitty Sheridan the
the wallpaper in the hallway was peeling
off the wall in my room the carpet was
wet I had to change my room twice and it
was 400 a night
yeah I don't yeah I I don't understand
that it outrageous people will pay it I
had to yeah but I that [ __ ] me up that
[ __ ] me up what I would like to do is
lit move into Joe's home and because
it's a big enough home yeah and I feel
like I should be able to live there I
would like to live there with you I
think many of us yeah Joey Diaz myself
you we should all live there we should
maybe move into the studio that's
another option I would take the studio
and I would sleep in the sauna I would
sleep yeah I haven't been there in a
while there's a sauna now dude his
Studio
it's so um
I look you know Joe himself is just he's
always been that just that he walks in a
room and you're like who's that right
right even though you know him you're
like what the [ __ ] he's got just such a
great energy right but that studio is is
overwhelming yeah like you know it's
overwhelming it's it's so like
nondescript and then you get in there
and you're like holy [ __ ] I mean all the
stuff he has in there the deprivation
thing the tech the sauna and and the gym
yeah I mean the coolest thing about all
of his Studios they've always been
nondescript yeah and the first time I
did the show it was so cool you just
pull
you know you pull into a parking lot
you're like what the [ __ ] is am I in the
right place yeah it's the first thing
you think yeah and then you see like a
Navy SEAL or some big beefy guy you're
like oh you get converged on yeah so
it's it's it is interesting that's my
one of my favorite things is that
they're never
you'll never know what it is until
you're inside until you're inside which
was insane and it's it's very and then
the studio is is nice it's not this huge
holy no this is cool cozy yeah thing and
you're right in there with them yeah and
uh yeah but it's it's epic and Tom's I
mean what they're doing in Austin I feel
like
it almost makes you want to go you know
let's get out of here yeah let's go
let's just go there get a house yeah and
and and I did I did that I know you I
know you're back I did that and I listen
when the club opens I'll spend time
there yeah I'll spend a lot of time I
may sell that house on Long Island no
are you mentally ill are you nuts you're
on crack go buy a house near me okay go
buy a house near me on a lake okay your
life will change and you know what else
your parties will have better people
perhaps you'll have no one which is
better dude you'll have actors all the
actors they don't live in the who the
[ __ ] lives in Long Island
oh I don't know but I didn't buy to live
around people it's you know dude you
have a party you want people to go we
got a good amount of comics come
oh
a lot of lower rent people yeah hey dude
but there was a few you know Louie
you know that was it
pretend there were others then there's
Sweet People sweet people yeah I would
ask you a question yeah the people that
you invited Normand came the normal
would come come on I know he'd come
whatever yeah he didn't care are you
going to his wedding no I I it's in New
Orleans I felt I feel like I want to go
then go I just like I just he's gonna
food's gonna be good and stuff yeah
that's so funny well you know what I
mean I love New Orleans New Orleans good
you know I actually said New Orleans
Food sucked a long time ago I went there
and you regret it I I trashed it I was
like you gumbo [ __ ] gumbo yeah your
jumbo [ __ ] Alia whatever it is I hated
it yeah and then he was like wow that's
good you got a Channing in and I went
back with Nick de Paulo and we went to
really good it's some of the best food
that was amazing I mean it was real
that's uh we did that's what we do yeah
we say [ __ ] remember we got in a fight
over Ray Donovan's it's a horrible show
I actually watched it I like it it's a
great show it's actually really good but
that's what we do we we come out and we
are like Austin and I want to let
everyone know that especially the people
at the eternal revenue service
foreign
I'm a comedian yeah and I say a lot of
[ __ ] but I love Texas and I'm a Texan
and we'll be very soon I might be a
Texan too you should be attacked I want
to don't you have like a guest house yes
you can no just come I don't care if you
read it can I can I just come stay there
I could have just why did I say did you
stay at my house I don't know why I I
was dude my house is no money either
like my mortgage is it's so cheap really
it's 2 900 a month
2 900 a month
I'm staying at your place next year just
stay there yeah I'll stay at the guest
house yeah up by the chickens
I wish there were chickens oh you have
deer you have deer we have a lot of deer
I saw a deer when we were there there's
a lot of deer I love your house too it's
not a bad house I'm liking Austin dude I
I'm I've always I've said nothing but
good things about it
I mean if we're gonna get on this route
I guess I mean that night we were
looking for I hate no I've publicly been
in a war with Austin for a year and a
half but like old Wars they have to end
yeah all all wars have to end Ukraine
and Russia will have to end me and
Austin will have to end LA's desolate
too L.A sucks too Ally's got good food
though great food I mean ridiculous
amounts really good yes it's gotten so
much better it's got great food I Gotta
Give La credit on food and I'm not
I'm not you know like that part of me I
don't do that anymore where I'm like you
know no I know I gotta where's the food
right because that's you know when I
used to come to L.A was where's the
hookers
and then it was where's the foot and
then it became where's the food right
now you're where where's the podcast
it's so sad it gets sadder and sadder
hookers food now it's pie where's the
podcast camakoto makes great Japanese
steel kitchen knives using traditional
techniques from Japan
kamakoto Builds on the legacy of over
800 years of Japanese technology and
expertise in creating the steel to make
knives that have been meticulously
handcrafted using traditional techniques
to date back to the Edo period of Japan
you see
it's it's a company and they're making
knives which everybody needs for the
holidays
each kamakoto knife goes to a rigorous
19-step process that takes several years
from start to finish to complete with
more than a hundred years of experience
between them our expert bladesmiths hone
and shape raw steel into Hardy blades
polishing and sharpening them to an
excruciatingly fine Edge
each knife comes with a beautiful heavy
duty Ash wood box it makes sure that the
knife is stored safely it also makes
kamakotas a great gift because of the
wooden box and knives are presented in
so if somebody's into steak they're into
wagyu stuff they're into cooking they're
into serving they're into having some
type of party these knife sets are
really cool and if you're serving meat
at your house and you open up one of
these wooden boxes people are going to
forget about all the things you said at
dinner that bothered them uh whatever
happens whatever that happened to be
minimizing the capital Riot whatever it
is that you
did you can then say and here is the
knife and people go great and they move
on
um knives are great knives are great
um it's such a cool thing to bring out
and show people almost as cool as a gun
um
so I'll tell you this right now thanks
to kamakoto for sponsoring this video
get an additional fifty dollars off on
any purchase with code Tim Dillon during
their Black Friday sale
so 50 off with any purchase with code
Tim Dillon during their Black Friday
sale go to kamakoto.com that's
k-a-m-i-k-o-t-o.com slash Tim Dillon and
help support the show it is always
Japanese steel they don't use anything
other than Japanese steel this is the
best deal you can get on these amazing
knives yeah I remember when I used to
come here and that's what it reminded me
of coming here tonight it reminded me of
getting a hooker back in the day because
you had to like go to an address and
then you had to call when you got there
and then they would come out they'd give
you the right address how would you know
which one to like where would you find
was it on back page or like what was
there was the uh La weekly okay uh you'd
get the LA weekly and in the back they
had the hookers
um and you could and they just had like
they would say like Hey I'm
you know they would have a picture of a
girl
and it was never that girl right it
would have this blonde girl you'd be
like oh my God and you'd show up and it
was a Spanish woman
in her 50s with zits and at that point
you're just like look it's three o'clock
in the morning uh let's just do this and
you'd go in and uh and and do what you
had to do what was the price back then
back then it was
um it was different prices it was a
hundred bucks usually or 120 bucks
but La is the worst for sex workers New
York was the best New York was the
ultimate because I don't know
it was a a better there was a um I think
because of porn was here I don't know
what they had they [ __ ] you a lot he
was always a scam New York it was you
know it was actually they had some type
of code where you kind of got what you
wanted right
um but in La it was always a scam it was
always [ __ ] like I showed up one
time at this place it was a hotel shitty
hotel and we showed up and uh she was
like yeah I can't touch you you can't
touch me but we get naked and you can
masturbate
and it's like I already gave you the
money
uh now I'm just sitting there and I'm
just I could have just done this in my
hotel yeah what is that well it's just
sex it's a bad you know it's like bad
stuff you know but you think you're
gonna you know hook up like in New York
you would go and you'd you'd go into a
room and you you know what do you think
sex work in Austin's like just a big
woman who smells like brisket she comes
out and she's she's just dangling burnt
ends like pasties over her tits she's
got like bikey tattoos and ashy elbows
she's she's technically a lesbian but
she's making side cash she's got cancer
freckles on her tits yeah she just comes
out with like that dikey green hair and
she's like I sucked a dick once I'll do
it again I owe tax money I'll do it
again if I have to
yeah I mean it's um
sectionality has never been good no
sexualities but horrible I mean it is
good I guess if you're going to the
orgies there's orgies just like eyes
wide shut [ __ ] where has to be I mean
you can't I'm not excited I've never
seen that I know but I just have to
believe it's because there's got to be a
reason that people live here
yeah but the yeah I don't I don't I've
never seen that the sex here is terrible
I almost got I almost got shot one time
[Music]
[Laughter]
I had a girl come to my hotel room it
wasn't the girl in the thing it was some
some angry she was angry and she was
like uh
she she just you know gave me an
attitude and then she but she came in
very nice and she took the money then
she started to give me all these rules
and I was like what the [ __ ] and then
she left
and uh her guy came up
and was like listen stop you know he had
a gun and he was like you know he's this
little white guy he's like stop messing
with her and I called the place back up
and I placed the complaint and I was
like no
this is [ __ ] you sent the wrong girl
it's not the girl and I complained I'm
like this is crap you know I've ordered
from you before I'm gonna tell everybody
I know and then they they go we're gonna
send her back up and they made her come
back up
and uh she came back up and what was her
attitude like then it was terrible but
so was mine okay so I just masturbated
in front of her and I made her dance
what a beautiful story
I go I go Just Dance and she was just
kind of doing this angry just pissed off
dancing and you're just jerking off
angry as well it was terrible it was
like the worst experience yeah I mean
but I didn't want my I wanted to get my
money's worth yeah you don't want to get
robbed no I almost got robbed yeah yeah
I'm so glad I'm out of that sex stuff
though that sex addiction was the worst
that was bad how do you get out of that
meeting a good woman yeah I mean yeah I
mean I I mean because you went from
drugs I went from drugs sex
food was the first right back when I was
a kid yeah and then it went to drugs
and went back to food when I went to
rehab then it went to sex and sex uh
after I you know got sober sex was I
just got addicted to it man it was
terrible it wasn't bad were you able to
have relationships in that yeah no it
was no I wasn't I was
it's just something I did you know I had
to I had to find it how to hunt it down
right I mean anytime I went to a hotel I
would open up the Yellow Pages and look
for massage parlors and look for you
know some weird thing just to fill the
hole and uh and then you know when I
went my girlfriend at the time my wife
now it was just
it was terrible I had a bottom and it
was like look she's gonna leave
you know she's gone you hit a bottom I
hit a button no no I heard I had to
bottom I mean we got close to that too a
couple times let's be honest
I heard I had to pop oh my God I was you
really had a problem
I'm like you had a real issue
man it was a couple times so when Dawn
was like ultimate give you an ultimatum
like you gotta clean it up yeah dude I
was out I tapped out I went to therapy I
had to get my [ __ ] together I uh it's
funny because every friend I have that
you know told me to let her go and just
oh you're a piece of [ __ ] stop you you
can't do it just let her go find
somebody she deserves you're a piece of
garbage we our group of people is you
would know you want you don't want to
get any advice from them ever the only
person that gave me a good advice was
was uh Colin Quinn yeah he said try to
change try and in eight months if you
can't a year you can't then at least you
tried if you don't you're gonna regret
it for the rest of your life right and
he was I listened to him yeah and I did
you always listen to him you gotta and I
did and he saved my life and he saved my
relationship with my wife now the mother
of my child and I got out of it right
you know I got out of it because it was
a it's a bad one man sex is a sex is a
bad one food is the worst
food is the worst because you can't
like well sexy you don't want you can't
get rid of either but you can you can
get rid of a lot of it yeah you could
not [ __ ] prostitutes and now your
girlfriend's back we could not you know
uh contribute to sex trafficking yeah
all that [ __ ] yeah but food did not get
jerked off to a next to a Pollo Loco
yeah at 11 but then but then the next
thing is eating in the Pollo Loco and
that's a problem too and well no that's
a good one Apollo Loco is good
yeah food is the worst because you can't
get away from it
and it feels just as good as sex food as
an addictive uh quality to that I feel
like few people understand
no they a lot of people don't they do
but they've never tapped into those
feelings even fat people when I talk to
other fat people I'm like oh you don't
even you don't even this isn't an
addiction for you you just are eating
like [ __ ] yeah and you're fat and you're
lazy but you don't you don't view it
like because I always viewed it like an
addiction right and I'm like you don't
even view it like that no they a lot of
them don't even view it like that no
it's it's a hard thing to uh
um it's a hard thing to be aware of
right because but when you are it
[ __ ] kills you yeah because you know
what you're doing and you know what
you're doing after because the food
addiction thing
it's I still order like a food addict
like today for lunch right I I knew I
what I can eat but I still ordered two
things
right I still order two things I've
never not ordered
to because number one you get one thing
you go what if it sucks it doesn't suck
but you go what if it's I remember going
through the drive-through at McDonald's
with my grandmother
and I ordered like three things and she
goes why don't you order one thing and I
went why and she goes because you're one
person yes and that was like that hit me
I was like oh she's ripe I've never
thought like that yeah no I I mean
McDonald's
to me it was like okay you get a large
fry right but you always want some more
fries right the lodge fry is not enough
right it is but it's not so what I would
do is get three large fries right I get
three large fries because I won't eat
them all but I'll never want another fry
that's a good point I like to get to the
point where I'm like I'm done I'm full
right and with three and then you put it
in the bag and you can just keep eating
until you like I'm full one large fry is
not enough
yeah I mean for me it's so hard to go
out and not get an appetizer or a few
yeah and then an entree and then they
come over and they're like dessert I
mean it's a problem it's nuts the way we
eat here if you think about it yeah
America does this no other country does
it does the the appetizer it like it's
the size of a dinner well you get the
appetizer which is a dinner and then you
get a whole meal yeah so you your plate
comes you just ate you just shared two
or three appetizers right yeah and bread
right we always get bread I don't know
what the [ __ ] bread thing is but we
always get bread at the beginning yeah
with butter
these are portion sizes around the world
they were looking at yeah exactly
and where's America there's United
States two cutlets two cups yeah two
cutlets but the thing that they're not
showing in this see this is what they
don't they they they're not showing the
before the before
like because here's here's the reality
is like
when you just you could get calorie
counts up that's what it really is you
go to like calorie counts at like a Red
Lobster or something like that one
entree is about 2 000 calories two
thousand calories one entree right of
like fried shrimp that linguine pasta
and some other [ __ ] like they have
to like pick three you know yeah and we
have more
uh fast food or theb restaurants
whatever you want to call them than
anywhere else yeah nobody has what we
have nobody you you don't go anywhere
when you go to a mall and you have the
Cheesecake Factory and [ __ ] Johnny
Rockets and [ __ ] every fast food
McDonald's
chipotle the food court the food court
everything yeah
Haagen-Dazs on a milkshake it's it's
it's nuts when you go to like a
Cheesecake Factory and you're getting an
appetizer of chicken wings you'll get
chicken wings before your meal a guy
would get chicken wings and I would
order a french fry for the table like
just get a fry for the table everybody
loves you I would get a chicken
quesadilla oh with guacamole as an
appetizer yeah I don't know if it's an
app it's probably not it's probably okay
I consider it an appetizer I would get
that I'd get the little stuffed mushroom
bites yep the little stuffed mushroom
bites okay I would do the Buffalo blasts
those are good those are good yeah and
then I would get like a burger and we'd
split it and I'd be with one other
person and we'd be eating like I get a
soup yeah I was gonna ask what the soup
is right and I get the bowl I'm not I'm
not I'm making I'm not getting a cup of
soup right I'll get the like a clam
chowder I'm in I'll get a salad whatever
right and then I'll get like a fried
calamari yeah and it's for everybody
right but then you get the meal but then
I'll get a steak I'll get a I'll get a a
rib eye a 16 a 16th hour I don't know I
think I've ever ordered a 10 ounce rib
eye we went to my age and took us out uh
to s w which is a steakhouse in Vegas
and me Sam Talent the guy that opens for
me
and we had I mean a shellfish Tower yeah
Carpaccio
[ __ ] Lobster ravioli then we had a
chateaubriand we had the sides we had
the desserts I felt when I walked out of
that table you just felt like
you could barely move yeah you feel like
you you feel like if anyone tried to
attack me right now I feel like an
anaconda that had just expanded with the
kill of a copy bar and you can't move
how did you how did you change your life
I
I was [ __ ] done dude I was done I was
done I just couldn't I couldn't be
fat anymore yeah I just couldn't do it I
couldn't I couldn't carry it around
I couldn't feel that way anymore I mean
I had heartburn every night I had to
take my socks off when I slept
because my feet were swollen uh my knee
hurt all the time
um
my heart rate i i i breathing I would
hear myself on podcast
I couldn't my heart everything was
Fallen it was gone and I just couldn't I
couldn't quit alcohol quit drugs come
this far do all this [ __ ] have a family
finally have done it
feeling they have a good life and then
I'm gonna I'm gonna [ __ ] get taken
out by pasta and pizza it just didn't
make sense to me anymore you know it's
like I can't I can't do it I had to give
it up I had to give up my first
addiction my friend it was my friend
yeah you know because I'm on the road a
lot I don't I don't really travel with
people and I I feel like Lily Tomlin on
this [ __ ] thing
um and I had to give it up I had to just
give it up this is the new hour that you
have which is brilliant is about a lot
of this stuff well some of it I'm do the
new hour I'm working on now is is kind
of about food more food addiction about
that you know my my six fats my first
fat my second fat my third fat this hour
we did with uh Louie it's it's he came
to me
after a show I opened for him and he's
like you know I I want to do your hour
because nobody would give me an hour and
he's like I want to direct your hour and
produce it I was like [ __ ] yeah
that's awesome and he was like what do
you got and I was like I got two hours I
got one on food and I got one I got a
bunch of other stuff he goes I just want
you to kill he goes I don't want a theme
thing I just want you to go up and do a
club set I want you to do it like you're
on the road you're at a club and you
just murder it for an hour right and I
was like great great so we picked Tampa
because Tampa's the [ __ ] the best uh and
the crowds are awesome and they're
supportive and uh Mike Calta my number
one best friends out there and uh the
whole the look of it is
it's uh Elvis's 68 Comeback Special
I wanted a 10 foot by 10 foot 12 inch
stage I want everybody around me you
know that look when he came out in that
yeah and we we created it at Coastal
creatives this place is just empty space
and we made it that's so [ __ ] cool
yeah it was great can we get Elvis's
special uh I'm curious as to what that
looks like so are you like in the round
it's not the round it's almost around
it's more of a square
um but yeah like if you look at like see
how the people are around him right in
the images yes yeah see like everybody's
around him right and if you bring up
yeah bring up my uh kill box Robert
Kelly kill box
and uh is I can't believe they kind of
they really got it you know what I mean
um yeah we and we made it
um yeah see that one right there the one
to the first one yeah see that
it's the same type of they didn't yeah
they did it it's the same Vibe and it's
uh
it's great that's a great shot too all
those people they're right up on you
yeah so why is you telling the jokes you
can see people laughing yeah I like that
I like the theater thing it's fine right
but I feel like it's um
it's just closed off
specials are tough they're hard I I hate
I I hate having them
I love live performance making it a
specials difficult
that's difficult it's hard to do because
it's you you're you're doing it on cue
yeah instead of going up this is
something at stake right like we I
talked to it before we uh 20 minutes
into my set on the first show this lady
almost died
and we had to stop the show yeah and we
had a you know everything and it just
[ __ ] threw me off yeah [ __ ] me up
that was in my head so I had to get the
next one what did she almost die of we
don't know she just passed out and she
was and her husband was crying and there
was a [ __ ] nightmare and you know the
whole room went from having a blast
right having the greatest time to like
this person's gonna die yeah and they
dragged her out and I guess she survived
to thank God her husband sent me a a DM
the next day she's okay yeah great yeah
but it was all right I mean but it was I
mean look like it's weird too because
now everybody like you have to pay for
my special yes but it's like look man we
didn't just go do this for ten thousand
dollars at a club which I'm fine with
we went and tried to make something
special yeah we tried to come up with a
thing and my in my head give it to Louis
his team and let's make it and let's put
it out there on his website and not ask
anymore you know to you know yeah so and
and we just did it and people like I'm
so happy they've been responding and
buying it and supporting it well they
should it's a great [ __ ] hour I saw
you do that hour in Round Rock Texas or
a good portion of that hour at a bar and
you murdered it was amazing yeah that
was yeah that was that was crazy so that
was the best hour I'd seen in a very
long time so it's like anyone not you
should absolutely go and buy that are
you are you happy when you look at like
the decision to do it
the way you did it
in that environment is that do you say
to yourself like that's great you want
to do that again
I don't know what you mean I don't know
either I don't know it's like I I shot
in Denver and I shot a big Theater in
Denver I go I don't want to do that
again
I want something else and it's not that
I hated it right I just you know the
fire alarm went off first show before I
went on
something always happens but to me I go
I would go smaller next time maybe yeah
I mean that's why I like doing these
specials the first one I did at the
village underground this one was here
and we created this space I think the
next one then the next one maybe I do a
theater maybe I do something a little
bigger yeah because I haven't done one
in the theater and it's you know when
you do a theater you do theaters all the
time it's it's a different performance
very it's not like I can In This Crowd I
can see people's faces yeah so you why I
wind up [ __ ] yapping to him there's a
lot of crap I put crowd work into it
like the rule we had is if it's funny
it's in yeah it's the best rule whatever
the whatever so crowd there was a crowd
work then that he left in I was like
great and now you don't have to do go
through somebody to say oh you should
take that out just [ __ ] it put it in I
was gonna call it remember AIDS
and you should have
and I was like we can't do that Lou was
like why not we can call it whatever we
want I don't know [ __ ] because you can
do whatever you want now because there's
no you're not asking anybody right
you're just doing it yeah and now that
Louie has his own site and your fan base
is gonna [ __ ] buy whatever you put
out because they love you I think that I
think that the the streamers are gonna
start letting you call it remember AIDS
too because they're all broke you think
so yeah they're they're losing a lot of
money man I didn't get any notes on that
special I think it's gonna go the other
way where people are like we got to make
money these are all businesses yeah
these guys will have mortgages yeah and
I think people forgot about that and
they're like oh but we could just win
Emmys and like have articles written
about us saying how great we are and
it's like eventually something's got to
make money yeah and something's got to
be good yeah I don't think it's gonna go
back to like where you know there's
always going to be things are going to
be a reflection someone of the time that
they're in yeah but that being said
I think Macon just woke garbage might be
over and they might people are like
let's make good let's make things that
are good yeah I think funny always wins
yeah in the end and I mean look at this
I'm I'm I don't have to back in the day
you had to do some radio tour that a
publicist set up and you had to go on
hey this is W.A Robert Kelly's kill box
and it was like holy I don't even know
these people I don't even know if they
like me some of them didn't you know
blah blah blah now I'm out here with you
at [ __ ] 11 o'clock at night in the
middle of nowhere uh shooting at your
studio yeah and thousands of people are
watching this yeah and you're my friend
right and we're just shooting the [ __ ]
it's easier I mean I just farted I think
I might have [ __ ] my pants right I think
I might have [ __ ] my pants
um I don't know if I pooped
um but yeah well you could [ __ ] on
morning radio too you can't you can't
[ __ ] on morning radio you can [ __ ] on
morning radio but not morning TV yeah
but yeah like this the whole thing
changed dude I'm yeah I'm hanging with
my friend right now out right doing your
podcast yeah and thousands of people
could go buy this thing yeah and and
should and it's like that's nuts right
that you're in control like all of our
podcasts all these friends of comics are
in control of the people that like them
now instead of CBS being in control of
all those people and controlling you
they're gonna win it they'll win in the
end who did the Industrial win in the
end why how they'll buy everything
they'll buy all this [ __ ] you think how
much would it cost for you from for me
yeah I'm CBS I want to own this how much
20 million
that's it yeah you're done yeah
look at he just he just look at his eyes
20 million bucks I if you because here's
the reality I go
okay if you write me a chapter own it
meaning what own it meaning like
you're on CBS something and you have to
go you have to you have to answer to
somebody
as long as I could do the show want to
do yeah but you'd have to answer answer
to somebody
um you have a 20 million I'll answer I
mean I just I'm gonna do what I do and
they know like if I'm envisioning that
if if they buy this stuff yeah they know
what it is yeah and they want to own it
for a reason yeah and the people that
like it like it for a reason but CBS is
not gonna buy it no so somebody like
Sirius or they might someone like that
somebody like that who you know is out
on the outskirts who kind of don't give
a [ __ ] who kind of do things anyways
they already have Stern and you know Jim
and Sam and and uh what Rogan's on is uh
Spotify they are taking risks yeah but
there's no way a network no or even a
case
a division of one of those companies I
do think that maybe streamers in the
future like look at some of this stuff
and go maybe they want it well like
Netflix
I don't know if Netflix but sometimes
Netflix hasn't bought a podcast I think
they just don't want the uh the the
smoke as they would say like they don't
want the uh potential problems right
they just don't want the controversy
right I think that's probably don't you
think that they're losing a lot of money
to podcasting don't you think like well
the problem with podcasts this has
always been the problem of the podcast
right you can't make this much better
like let's say Netflix put it in that
studio and they got a staff and had all
these people you go it doesn't make it
much better right this is why they don't
[ __ ] with us because they if you look at
a a sketch that somebody did online they
could go we could make that a show right
with this there's not much you can do
like
I guess you could make it real time but
it's not real time but you know what I
mean like they can't do that much right
with any of this stuff I think that they
can still do a lot when they're making
movies right and when they're making
shows
but with this like the the reality of
what this is is just
people shooting the [ __ ] some of them
being funny yeah
it's it is it is crazy that you yeah
have your own Studio yeah which is
Awesome by the way thank you and you can
just roll in you just got out of a plane
yeah me and you were sitting here
talking to thousands of people and it
doesn't it is one person there's a some
technology and you hit a couple buttons
and you're gone that's crazy it's crazy
that's technology but there's limits to
it too right the limits are
it's not gonna ever replace Step
Brothers
or or Tommy Boy right or Anchorman
Howard The Birdcage
what movie that came out is like that
none of them but I'm saying the person
in this world to whirl in yeah who finds
a way to make a 90-minute comedy the way
that all comedies that we grew up with
were it's gonna change the game because
I'm telling you I love podcasting it's
my my you know I love it that being said
it's a it's a lot of things but what it
isn't is what I just said
it's not those things so the person who
figures out a way to do a movie
like that and I don't mean Louie who's
already established and already
brilliant I mean a guy in our group
right who figures out a way to fund and
do a film yeah that's gonna be a game
changer yeah but the film has to be I
think the the comedies aren't funny
anymore
it's got to be funny it's got to be it's
got to be [ __ ] up it's got to be very
[ __ ] up there's got to have very hits
in it I think tits have to come back
tits have to come back TNA and they can
be trans tits yeah 100 100 I prefer
because with that you can even show the
penis I'm for it all 100 yes I'd love to
see a trans huge naked T instead of TNA
T and D just a fun comedic and people
are getting aroused yeah it's great oh
my God [ __ ] yeah I'd love to see that
like Porky's but trans Kentucky Fried
Movie yeah with trans yes fantastic man
that's the pitch was there any what was
it with a trans oh uh
um
well we'll be with the Trans it was um
the the [ __ ] Zach Galifianakis movie
The Hangover Hangover had trans robs she
had a she writes Tang over two I don't
remember yeah you're probably right oh
yeah oh I believe me I remember I'm a
big fan of the train well straight guys
are very into trans now yeah I don't
know what it is yeah it's big so let's
should go in the movie yeah it was
definitely yeah there she is yeah trans
smoking hot
look at her yeah
um yeah I think the next movies that are
going to come out that are going to make
an impact are going to be [ __ ]
outrageous yeah Politically Incorrect
[ __ ] up real life [ __ ] because that's
the one thing we can't do ourselves or
we can we gotta figure out how to do it
ourselves we could do talk shows
ourselves
stand up all that [ __ ] I mean talk shows
this is what a podcast is we took over
late you know late night TV doesn't
matter anymore crazy yeah late night TV
is [ __ ] this is like doing a late
night show that's different yeah but so
but the one thing we haven't figured out
is is movies store a lot of money yep
there's a lot of moving Parts yep gotta
work with a lot of different people
right these things are hard for Comics
but the person who figures it out
is going to change the game I think Burr
has a movie coming out that's going to
be something like that
okay I think he might yeah I think
somebody's gonna do it I think he's
already kind of done he's been in a
million but I'm I'm also talking about
like these those guys are like they're
legendary got like they should have
movies anyway right I'm talking about
like from the ground up and this might
be from the ground up with him I don't
know yeah but I mean like from the
ground up
the person who goes I've also made this
thing
and here it is and you can buy it that's
going to be huge yeah when it happens
yeah
yeah it's not gonna be me
don't say that why
what are you talking about I have a tiny
house in New Hampshire
Helix is great I have all Helix
mattresses in my house they were nice
enough to send me a bunch Helix has a
quiz that you take two minutes to
complete it matches your body type with
the type of mattress you want you want a
firm mattress you want a medium mattress
do you want a soft mattress it's really
amazing how great they are and how cheap
they are many people spend thousands and
thousands of dollars on mattresses
they're not nearly as good as a helix
everybody I've had over my house who
slept in the guest room goes wow this
mattress is great
um and they go what kind of mattress it
is I'm like it's a helix they're like no
way and they lose their mind they're
like you're a [ __ ] liar I'm like I'm
not a lot like you lie about a lot of
[ __ ] and then we get in a fight but
Helix is one of the really great
companies out there
um I'm telling you if you try it usually
don't you realize oh you don't have to
spend all that money
um so that's what we're doing right now
you know we're doing an ad for Helix but
I believe in Helix and I sleep on Helix
and I even and I donate Helix mattresses
to unhoused people on the street if I
see them I will pull over and we'll
we'll stack a couple of helixes in a van
and you know
will send them out to them and um we
have them take the quiz first and find
out how they like to sleep what are they
a side sleeper
and that's a big problem with the
unhoused population right now in Los
Angeles and building
housing for them is the beds and are you
a side sleeper do you sleep hot do you
sleep cold are you a stomach sleeper do
you like firm do you like soft this is
huge and this survey has gone out to all
40 000 homeless people and they're still
returning it and that's the biggest
problem that we're having we have a
mayor's race next week but as soon as we
get the 40 000 Helix sleep quizzes back
from the homeless population in Los
Angeles California we will be able to
start to construct the affordable
housing
um if you want a great deal on this
mattress they're offering up to 200 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at helixsleep.com
Tim D
you want some you want some deals for
the holidays Helix sleep.com slash Tim D
they're offering 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners
so many of my friends are losing their
hair and they're bald and there's
nothing they can do about it but here's
something you can do about it save the
hair that's already on your head how do
you do that a witch doctor a voodoo
priestess a packed with the Devil
no how about keeps
keeps how about that I'm telling you
right now it is a hair loss medication
that allows you to retain the hair that
you have on your head okay it is a hair
loss treatment
it is awesome it's prescription
medication delivered at home online
doctor consultations it's not a lot of
money you can do it virtually convenient
online virtual consultations medications
delivered straight to your door every
three months they have 24 7 care and
support
um treatments could take four to six
months to see results so when you start
losing your hair what you really want to
do is start on this regimen and that it
will allow you to keep your hair uh the
one that you have so you don't have to
get a wig you don't have to start doing
a hair I know a guy that recently just
got a hair surgery and it there's
everyone can tell there's something
wrong so if you can keep your natural
hair for as long as you can with keeps
you're doing a lot better
than the freak who's a literal freak now
you know he was someone that we all
liked but he had a hair surgery where he
had hair surgically put onto his head
and now he's a freak and he's disgusting
and he's been ostracized and cast out of
the community and because he did
something and we we go because we can
all tell that there's something wrong
with it whereas if he had just started
keeps and kept his natural hair it would
be so much easier to like stomach him
look him in the face and treat him like
a human
if you're ready to take action to
prevent hair loss go to keps.com Tim
Dillon receive your first month of
treatment for free that's keps.com Dylan
to get your first month free keps.com
Tim Dylan I'm telling you right now it
is amazing you'll love it hair is great
happy holidays well I I don't know I
don't know I it's hard it's difficult
because you gotta have the right idea
well you gotta have money dude gotta
have money in the right idea
I have the time I have a show that I'm
filming in the summer
comedy Camp I have to tell you about
that no
it's happening
okay
it's uh it's a show that I'm I'm ready
where you take comedians camping I take
comedian you ever see the show alone
no all right there's a show called alone
and they take 10 people up into the
woods
and they drop them off three miles five
miles seven miles apart from each other
and whoever lasts the longest wins oh
this show is I'm taking five comedians
up into the woods
and for five days
but there's no it's literally hiking up
into the mountains
making a camp and living for five days
with five comedians that's gonna be
tough it's gonna be tough and this is
based on the thing you do with Ari and
Joe list it's based on it's kind of
Bushcraft party boys and what do you
guys do again you go into like the
waywards we
I love that you talk about like yes you
go up into the woods I've never been
invited I'm I'm an alien dude I would
take you out we'll do it this summer
yeah but yeah we're filming it yeah
Russell Peters is an island but you
can't do the woods in Long Island
there's no Hills there's no Hills it's a
[ __ ] flat place there's enough Hills
there's no mountains
just Cliffs there's no you can't
Bushcraft in a cliff Tim okay you can't
so Russell Peters is doing this Russell
Peters Bill Burr okay Jim Norton
okay you got a group we got uh Beth
Stallings hopefully Shack that she's
doing it
and we're we're literally you should get
Whitney in there Whitney he'll kill Olia
Whitney would be great I mean he should
be fantastic but I mean no cell phones
no internet no managers no nothing no
how do you shoot the show Crafts
everybody it's like the show alone
everybody has the cameras on them
and we have a a one a camera person
that's shooting yeah people are gonna
die Bobby
people are gonna die what are you
talking about people what do you mean
what am I talking about people are gonna
die nobody's going to die you're gonna
have blood on your hands
gonna have blood all over your hands
should be dripping off your hands what
are you talking about people are gonna
die how are they gonna die not able to
you're not able to survive in these
conditions listen it's not going to be
we're going to have supplies okay so now
we get to the real hang on let's get to
the reality listen we're gonna have
supplies not like they're gonna have to
hunt for their food okay see they show
up and they have a tent and food they
have to well first of all they have to
set up their Camp they have they have to
set up they have to we have to it's it's
called Uh primitive camping so we
there's no campsite it's not about
glamping where it's glamorous no okay no
no no no it's it's primitive camping so
you we're hiking up into a certain place
we have a guy that's going to take us
well I have well you have a Coleman tent
you'll have a uh a tarp okay you'll have
a tarp and
disperse camping but you're yes you're
gonna turn giving to camping in the
United States on public land other than
designated campsites this type of
camping is most common National Forest
so this is the type of stuff we're gonna
basically hike up four hours into the
woods find a spot make camp and you'll
have to do certain tasks
start a fire get firewood uh uh have a
solo night out by yourself you're gonna
have to like Norton's gonna have to go
out in the woods
we're going to find a place set up a
camp build a structure to protect
himself
and sleep out by himself at night I'll
ask a good question yes sir
why and because
you have I mean have you ever been out
in the woods I have have you ever known
what's your evil
it's true they're Pagan I I'm a
Christian I believe in the oceans and
the mansions and the rolls royces
because I'm a Christian I'm a follower
of Christ the woods are pagan and
satanic I don't love the woods the woods
are beautiful and quiet and it's one of
the only places you can go where you can
go back in time to where it was a much
simpler place where you are not with
your addictions you're not with your
compulsions you're not with this
excitement or huge highs or really lows
it's just good
I do enjoy I will say it is a nice
campfire and some stuff is fun there's
nothing like being out with no phone
could I bring like a Bush's Baked Bean
like the grilling beans you if you do
the show if you do it of course you okay
I'll allow you baked beans for one night
but okay so everybody because you're
saying that they're not gonna have to
hunt for their food well we're gonna
look into that because if because well
if we could uh set you're gonna have to
we could set snares for certain things
or fish uh fishing is going to be a big
thing yeah Russell Peters by the way has
like 19 Bentleys does he know he'll be
snaring the food or you don't know
Russell peters's background I'm sure is
it in India and does it involve water
that's not clean it involves Tigers yeah
I get it he's done the father used to
hunt tigers that's nuts and he went with
him as a boy
and and actually will you be camping
where there are tigers no this is gonna
be no time okay there's gonna be no
target but there it's gonna be Wildlife
man this is fun that's gangster that's
him man that tiger
he's shot as it was jumping up to kill
him
well I'm against the murder of the uh
the animals like well over there you you
know I get it because they're coming to
the Village so yeah that's what the
environmentalists don't realize they
come into the village and snatch kids
and monkeys are thieves yes yeah yeah
but yes this is gonna be it's gonna be
to take a Norton Jim Norton out and take
him out of the penthouse the cabs the
car the cell phones all the stuff that
all sounds great and to put him up in
the woods
five days five is a lot Bobby well
there's one up one up and one down okay
three it's well uh probably four days
and I would say I would say six days is
coming down so you're gonna have four
days up in the woods okay so so we have
to set up camp you have to you know
doing Upstate New York it's either gonna
be in Upstate New York or it's going to
be in Canada and Toronto oh so it's it's
gonna be crazy man because when the Sun
goes down like I I've gone up with
people like me and Ari and Joe have gone
up I've taken Paul verzi up in the woods
just me and him you hike up a couple
hours you you make a spot and then
you're having a good time and then the
sun goes down and the whole world
changes now explain that because that
sounds very gay and very cool yeah we
just
sucking each other off because there's
nobody around when you say the sun goes
down and the whole world
[Music]
that sounds like the gayest thing I've
ever heard
no dude it's now when you see this
because it gets dark does he is when it
gets dark out and the woods you
understand like in the city you can't
see stars right because the lights of
the city but when you go out in the
woods there's no lights of the city so
that you can see galaxies [ __ ]
turning you know what I mean yeah no I
do know it's a different thing and but
you can't see in front of your face and
then your eyes adjust and all of a
sudden you're in complete darkness the
only thing you have is the fire
and there's nobody around for two hours
and when you hear something it's
something right it's not nothing right
it's something right and you have to
deal with that you're describing the
Bronx
[Music]
it's very similar yeah okay
you have the same fears yeah but I
listen I get I like the idea of
because what you're basically saying is
that you're trying
you're trying to get to a part of
yourself
that has been that Comics don't get to
the the comics don't get to we don't get
to man we're going from what about Rogan
he gets to it because that's his whole
world absolutely guess they like air
drop him into a volcano and he like
haunts like the three-legged lizards or
something yeah dude Rogan gets it you
know Callan has got he gets it you know
like there's certain guys that get it
but this this you know certain friends
of mine Comics but the thing that you
know when you do this with regular
people right
they're talking about they're just still
those same people when you bring comics
on a hike it's [ __ ] hilarious right
when you're up by a campfire with Comics
dude the amount of you know the funny
[ __ ] that's it's so funny you know it's
like you you're smashing people you're
talking about these things you're going
off and it's it's great but all of a
sudden something is coming in the woods
and it's like what the [ __ ] is that it's
like it's cool yeah you become real it's
like all of a sudden it's it's it's no
joke anymore because you're you're
stripped down stripped down you're out
there in the woods and you yeah it's and
have your fears your insecurities your
whatever and you're in there and you're
still a comic and you're still using
that defense mechanism right to con
that's your armor yeah but it's real
[ __ ] it's real we don't ever get to be
real
out there that that's very true we I'm
always seeing
the funny Tim Dillon version right when
we hang out we're always trying to make
each other laugh yeah if me and you're
up in the woods you're gonna see that
too and the Sun goes dude and the sun
goes down I get funnier dude if
me and you were in the woods yes if you
were on the show and and
you know it's pitch dark out it's 11
o'clock at night and you're not going
home for a couple days and you're gonna
crawl into some tent into a sleeping bag
on a sleeping pad
you're going to be a different guy the
next day that's true you're not gonna be
the second day and the third day you're
gonna be different
because you're not going to have a
shrimp scampi or a [ __ ] quesadilla
you know it's you're gonna you're not
gonna have the microphones what do you
see happen to people you've done this
before what happens on that second or
third day when there is no shrimp scampi
or quesadilla what happens to these guys
what what do they become you you become
like you you get you become
um a truer version of yourself no you be
you you you actually get to be yourself
interesting you actually become yourself
interesting because you you're actually
looking at things and appreciating them
and when you get back to your house and
the the the AC's on and your pillows are
on the bed and you open a fridge
and you you you you
you appreciate it a lot more it's a dude
I I do I will say that I've done not
kind of what you're describing but I've
done similar things where
I have then gone home and you appreciate
home yeah dude I've been to Guatemala a
couple times yeah with my friend and we
just went and it's rough and crazy and
scary and petrifying and
and when you get home after that trip
you just like I'm so glad to be live in
America I'm so glad
I can drink the shower water yeah you
know um it's like I love my life it
makes you appreciate what you got have
you ever thought of doing it would you
take Comics to the Bronx
and you put them and night falls and
they have to set up a can it's the same
show but it's just easier to shoot
because it's in them it's too dangerous
it's it's I understand what you mean and
I feel like what but I I do love the
beach and the ocean and that to me is
right to walk on the beach
I'm telling you what's gonna attack you
a middle-aged [ __ ] gay guy trying to
suck you off no that's more dangerous to
many people you know than a lion first
of all
tigers are much easier to deal with than
Jews so if you were on a beach
if you were on a beach in the Hamptons
my whole point is that like their nature
isn't just the woods it's not just the
woods the ocean's tough I've been in
Riptides I've almost died in Riptides
have you ever been in a Riptide I've
been in a [ __ ] real you swim diagonal
yeah well I didn't know that at the time
but the point is nobody knows that yo I
didn't know it but you're right and you
they have lifeguards that [ __ ]
everywhere I not where I am
I did the town of Southampton is a
commonwealth the ocean is a [ __ ] is is I
don't like it it's not fun it's more
powerful than the woods you know it is
you know the ocean's more powerful than
the woods the feminine is more powerful
than the masculine and you know it the
ocean's big [ __ ] okay fine the I will
give you that the ocean is more powerful
than the woods but the woods the woods
are better
no the woods are better no 100 no dude
the ocean is the same [ __ ] every day
because it's dope dude
we have seasons in the forest I do so I
do like the idea of that are you
thinking about is this a fall thing it's
got It's Gonna be in the spring because
we gotta go after mud season because
when the winter after the winter the
mountains
um the snow melts and and the woods
become very muddy and then there's fly
Seasons bug season when the bugs all
hatch that's the summer and you don't
well that's the beginning of the summer
there's a certain time when the black
flies is that you don't want to be in
the woods at that time it's a nightmare
during the day so we gotta we want to go
uh either in the spring or the late
summer you know uh now September is a
good time to go because there's no bugs
it's cold at night and uh you know we
wanted to we don't want it to be too hot
we don't want it to be too [ __ ] up
because I don't want to break these guys
I don't want them to know you know
that's what I thought you were gonna do
well let me tell you something dude you
know the the winner of it you know you
win by you know doing certain tasks well
you know uh so you get certain you get
what would what would a task be like
sucking someone off
can that be a task
wow
it's gonna be interesting
oh that's
you're gonna get Girl Scout patches okay
like a sash you're gonna have a sash
yeah and whoever completes the most
tasks
um
and you know they they we're gonna give
money to charity I'm paying for all this
this is [ __ ] awesome yeah the money's
going to charity so that as people what
kind of Charity you take the homeless
people whatever to the woods no whatever
they
whatever they want like it'll be the
person's charity oh nice so they'll pick
the charity but yeah like starting a
fire Jim Norton starting a fire is
hilarious is going to be hilarious yeah
it's gonna be because we're going to
teach him how to do it and then he's
going to have to do it so he's not going
to be able to do it and he's not but if
he does it it'll be amazing if Jim
Norton comes back it's really good who's
a comic where you go this person's gonna
ace at all well Drogan of course right
uh Rogan would be great maybe not well
like when I went out with Ari and Joe
you know they didn't know how to hang a
bear back right you know you know when
you take a [ __ ] you have to you have to
go 150 feet away from the camp or water
and you have to dig a hole and you have
to [ __ ] outside
and then buy 150 feet because you can't
it's
um it's just the rules like you don't
you where we make a camp
uh like primitive campsites that we find
you can't [ __ ] near the campsite or
water it's just a certain amount because
you because that if that gets into the
water well you don't want [ __ ] near the
campsite you know what I mean okay it's
just that's the well that I get that I
understand yeah [ __ ] outside is one
of the greatest shits you'll ever take
right once you get over the fact that
you're [ __ ] outside you know you
lean up against a tree you dig a hole in
the ground you [ __ ] in the hole you will
[ __ ] rope it's amazing
it's the way we [ __ ] for hundreds of
years thousands of years of what what
when do we stop doing that like 200
years ago it's not that far
you know people [ __ ] in outhouses a
hundred years ago right up in the woods
you know up in New Hampshire but a lot
of these bear bag is a bear bag you have
to take all your food and hang it in a
tree because you'll attract animals
like a bear a bear you don't want a bear
coming into camp and you have a [ __ ]
granola bar like if you did it we'd have
to pat you down at night before you went
in your tent have you ever seen a bear
yes
where in New Hampshire
what's it like
it's incredible man they're [ __ ] I
mean they're just as
they look adorable and cute but they'll
murder you so what do you do if you're
in the woods yeah yeah look at that man
look at that
that's like that I mean if you're in the
woods yes I'm in the woods now and
you're all in the tents yeah
bear comes into Camp yeah what is the
protocol
well we're good
we're gonna have bear spray
um when you spray the trees and stuff no
you spray the face it's mace for Bears
okay but people don't know that it's
actually less potent than regular mace
interesting human mace is worse than
bear sprays okay but it's terrible it
really hurts yeah we'll have them we'll
have that
um the guide is going to take us up and
then leave and I will be the person
which is a little scary I guess
terrifying why well because you know I
you know you want to guide well I'm your
guide well okay I mean you know but if a
bear comes well you know I mean look it
is there is danger to it but that's the
thing Tim I I'm not saying I'm not
saying let's avoid the danger I'm
shooting the bear comes in what do we do
you spray it in the face well yeah you
go you bear you you know it depends I
mean it's going to be I hope it's if
it's in Toronto I believe it's it's
black bears I don't think there's any
brown bears brown bears brown bears are
a problem right they're a problem you
don't want that so we're gonna do it
where there's you know what if there's a
brown bear a brown bear it's a problem
you don't want that what if a brown bear
eats best selling is it still a fun show
it's a popular show it's a very popular
show but a brown will be black bears
black bears can be dangerous too but you
know they don't really want nothing to
do with you right
um you know you know they kind of you
know when you're there you know Brown a
black bear you can kind of scare away
hopefully you know they're dangerous
what other dangerous things are in the
woods there's uh rattlesnakes yeah uh
timber rattlesnakes there's uh you know
mountain lions there's uh Fisher Cats
there's uh a lot of [ __ ] man I mean are
you gonna have any anti-venom with you
no
well I mean you probably should right I
mean
I mean Anti-Venom is probably a smart
thing to have if somebody gets bit by a
snake we're gonna do what we're supposed
to do yeah but you can still get bit by
a snake you can you can but so then you
just die no you don't die if you get bit
by rattlesnake you don't die well I mean
you could right I'm not saying you can't
you don't want to get bit by a
rattlesnake but you know we're not gonna
it's not like we're gonna be
it's not like we're we're gonna make
camp and we're gonna do things at camp
and then we're gonna go out together
so we're going to be careful I mean okay
that's one of the things I mean you're
gonna have to like when me and Ari and
Joe went up there's timber rattlesnakes
up in the UP UP in up in the uh
mountains where we went and that was
there's hundreds of them so when we were
hiking we had to be very careful of
where we were stepping and you would
hear them you you hear them sometimes
yeah sometimes it's just so if there's
three people it's sometimes the second
person is the person who gets bit wow
you know so you have we had to be
careful they're up there's a hundred of
them thousands of them up where we went
up in the Catskills which you don't
think but up in the Catskills there's
thousands of rattlesnakes and they're
big and you got to be careful there's
Bears we had a pack of coyotes come in
in the middle of uh in the night
1 30 in the morning a pack of coyotes
came in
well they're little they're in L.A they
walk around the streets they're like
little dogs they'll kill you oh a pack a
pack will what did you do when they came
in we did nothing we were just
frightening our tents
it was the most terrifying thing in the
world are you texting each other no
there's no phone you say anything from
110 yeah the Joe list after they started
to stop screaming yo list went what do
we do about that
yeah that's funny and I said I don't
know
so yeah see this is gonna be listen this
is gonna be very interesting and I think
it's gonna it's gonna someone will die
but that's okay
No No One's Gonna Die oh someone will
die No One's Gonna Die Why is somebody
gonna die because it just it seems like
a lot of things you could kill someone
yeah there's a lot of things that kills
somebody but I mean people I don't think
you should I think you should lean into
someone dying you want the show to be a
show
it should be where one person someone
gets sacrificed somebody should who do
you think would die out of that mix
who's the mix again bill
repeaters
bathroom Norton or me
it'd be funnier if it was you only
because then only because they would
then it would be like if someone else
has shown them
and then that person might would you
take it over if I die
no well it would depend
I would I would feel you know I don't
know you could do it on the beach you
could do like a campfire on the beach at
night it like here's my variety kid
here's my version of the show yeah
here's my version all right let me hear
five comedians we all go to the shore
yeah sure the ocean yeah we swim out
with the great whites yeah [ __ ]
dangerous yeah come back in yeah we get
[ __ ] fish sandwiches we get [ __ ]
Mr Softy yeah we let up Carvel we
[ __ ] relax
do a bonfire on the beach do a bonfire
on the beach yeah maybe play a little
football yeah Night Football yeah have a
little fun we don't need to we don't
need to go into the woods like nuts
kind of capital Riot show is this will
you come with me this summer I will do
it no I actually I got jealous when you
went with Ari and Joe I would love to go
and experience this will you can you
hike of course I can all right relax I'm
just asking Ike I'm just saying when was
the last time you went hiking
well I mean in Los Angeles there's hikes
I've gone hiking the Runyan Canyon is in
a [ __ ] hike well no there's other
hikes besides that what
there's there's places I've hiked out
here Agora Hills and [ __ ] but I mean
like a like a two-hour hike
that seems a little nuts two hours but
it's enough yeah
I can hike all right so this summer
you'll be in New York me and you'll go
on an overnight yeah and that will go up
we'll [ __ ] well I got a perfect place
we'll go well High cup will make Camp
we'll have dinner
you know we could go go to the Mohawk
Mountain House what's that you ever be
there it's a big Wilderness Lodge no
we're not five star chefs why
yeah
oh no they give you picnic baskets you
can go out and eat
no we're gonna we're gonna sleep I got a
hammock you can sleep in my hammock okay
that sounds fun and we'll do a night out
in the woods we'll hike will light a
fire we'll get we'll get firewood okay
cool there's a lake we can jump in the
lake because as Jeffrey Dahmer said when
the when the lights when the when the
Sun goes down it's a whole different
world
Bobby tell people where to buy your
special that's the funniest hour of
Comedy I've seen in a very long time
it's at lewisckay.com and it's uh only
10 bucks and uh go buy it even if you
don't like me go buy it go buy it
support comedy I don't even care if you
watch it don't watch it don't worry buy
it not watch it oh it is one of the best
hours I've said that before on the show
that I've seen it's amazing thanks buddy
go buy it I'm gonna buy it I haven't yet
but I'm going to buy it you gonna buy it
I'm gonna buy it I you know what I buy
other comic specials and I don't know
why we all don't buy our children I
don't haven't done that yet but I will
do it you'll buy I want to see the
receipt I will absolutely send it to you
I want you to tweet it well I'm gonna
show it to you in the woods I don't have
a phone
do I want to do that with you we're
going to do it all right great fine
Bobby Kelly the special is called kill
box
Louis ck.net louisa.com
pillbox.com I'm hungry as [ __ ] I'm
hungry too can we eat can we can do
something we'll do something I mean I'm
gonna eat a little bit but I'm hungry
that's fine okay killbox.com Louis
ck.com the one the only Robert Kelly one
of the first people to put me on a
podcast we were talking about that on
Bert Show today yeah cause I I told him
I like I love putting new guys on and I
remember when I saw you yeah and it's
the same thing when I saw Dan soda yeah
I had Dan Soto the first time I was like
this guy is the [ __ ] and uh I when I saw
you I was like this guy you just got it
well I appreciate you were one of the
first people to throw me on something
you are you're the greatest right out of
the gate I remember we did that remember
Opie and Anthony took a day off I'll be
took a day off and I replaced him and I
had you in and you dress I painted your
face like a clown and then I look like
Charlie Casey and then Colin Hay came on
yeah
remember I offended him because I said
the joke about his dead friend yes and
he got mad it was good but then he had
to play the song and then you know
something you have to pretend everything
was okay it was bad it was fun but bad
that was great yeah it was fun but bad
yeah that's that's my life fun but bad
Bobby Kelly thank you so much thanks for
having me on man I appreciate it brother
of course thank you